المنتخب السعودي تخطا عقبه التانجو مباراه
كانت قمه في الشراسه والديه هزمت
الارجنتين في مستهل مشوارها لكن ربما لهذه
الخساره المدويه دلاله اخرى فهناك منتخبات
كبيره سقطت في اول اختبار لها في
المونديال ووصلت للمباراه النهائيه عام 54
سقطت المانيا الغربيه في مباراتها الاولى
امام هنغاريا والمفاجاه ان الالمان احرز
كاس البطوله وفي عام 90 خسيره الارجنتين
مباراتها الاولى امام الكاميرون لكن رفاق
مارادونا وصلوا للنهائي وفي 2006 يفشل
الفرنسيون في اول لقاءين في المونديال الا
ان ديوك يصلون للمباراه النهائيه وفي
مونديال 2010 يسقط الماتور الاسباني امام
سويسرا في المباراه الافتتاحيه لينجح
الاسباني في تحقيق لقب المونديال فهل
تفعلها الارجنتين بعد هزيمه مره امام
الاخضر السعودي